- [Announcer] This is Sissel Tolaas.
She is many things.
An artist, a scientist,
but more importantly, a smell expert.
She, however, prefers another title.
- [Announcer] Which means what, exactly?
- [Announcer] Right, the point is,
she's dedicated her life
to the sense of smell,
what it means, and how it can be used
to understand the world and each other.
- [Announcer] So how
exactly did she go about
recording and then reproducing
these smells?
- [Announcer] Name a city,
a neighborhood within
a neighborhood, a
historical building, or even
an era in time, and most
likely Sissel has reproduced
that smell, along with
thousands of other scents
here in her lab, with the
hopes of using the findings
for a bigger purpose.